[Music]
but also the persons of the divine being
itself as well as the character of its
substance coalesce into the simplicity
of what is without consciousness this
necessity has in contrast to
self-consciousness the characteristic of
being the negative power of all the
shapes that appear a power in which they
do not recognize themselves but on the
contrary
perish
the self appears merely as a sign to the
characters not as the mediating factor
of the movement
but self-consciousness the simple
certainty of self is in fact the
negative power the unity of zeus of
substantial being and of abstract
necessity it is the spiritual unity into
which everything returns
because actual self-consciousness is
still distinguished from the substance
and fate it is partly the chorus or
rather the crowd of spectators whom this
movement of the divine life fills with
fear as being something alien or in whom
this movement as something close to them
produces merely the emotion of passive
sympathy
partly too so far as consciousness is
involved and belongs to the characters
this union is an external one is a
hypocrisy because the true union that of
the self fate and substance is not yet
present
the hero who appears before the
onlookers splits up into his mask and
the actor into the person in the play
and the actual self
paragraph 742 now begins a very
important transition and it's a double
transition that's going to be taking
place in this and the next paragraphs
moving us first within this section into
comedy which is going to be mentioned
two paragraphs from now
and into the next large section the last
section of religion which is the second
to last section of the entire
work and we can say that the mask is
going to become thematized and in some
respect separated from
the actor there's a lot of mask language
going on here which we'll talk about in
just a moment
and the mask isn't coming off quite yet
that's going to come in the next
paragraphs but it's certainly being
focused on by the end of this section
so this one begins
by talking about persons of the divine
being itself the character of its
substance i mentioned we'd get to some
mask language later now's later so
persons persona
is a latin term that translates prosopon
which can be translated as face but also
as the masks that the the actors would
wear
in ancient
drama right and so we've already got
some
some mention of this going on the
persons of the divine essences are not
like you know the persons of the trinity
or anything like that they're rather the
representations the four shelling that
are being put forward as what they are
and notice that miller says divine
beings the german here is actually
goltnika
visan
so we're talking about essence not just
being
and then he talks about the character
character
of their substance again miller's
missing that in in this
it's substance right it's what's the it
the divine being the divine essences
zeina right so
we we have not just a single divine
being but all these these beings and we
notice that they're going to
like he says the persons of the divine
being itself a character coalesce into
the simplicity of what is
what is without consciousness this is
very interesting right because now we
don't have just a
opposition between
you know bovus sign consciousness and
zelps bavusan self-consciousness
we have a
split occurring between what lacks
consciousness altogether what can
actually only be
an object or a force
that
self-consciousness as a kind of
consciousness is going to encounter
and figure
so he tells us that
this necessity note vendikite has in
contrast to self-consciousness the
characteristic of being the negative
power we're going to get two negative
powers here the negative power of all
the shapes that appear a power in which
they now we have to be careful here do
not recognize themselves it's not on air
canon it's just air cannon
they don't recognize they don't know
they don't have familiarity
with what they are and that makes
perfect sense if they don't have they
not only don't have self-consciousness
they don't have consciousness how are
they going to have any sort of
recognition of anything and then he says
they
don't recognize themselves but perish
the self
appears merely as assigned to the
characters not the mediating factor of
their movement so the self
that's involved here if there is indeed
any sort of self
is not doing any sort of self-like work
and it may as well not even be a self
then he shifts over to talking about
self-consciousness
self-consciousness the simple certainty
of self is in fact
the negative power so where is it is a
real negative power lie
there's kind of a
you know there's a negative power here
but it's not really going to its roots
the self is the genuine
uh negative power he says the unity of
zeus of substantial being and of
abstract necessity so that sounds pretty
good it sounds like everything that's
important on this side of necessity is
actually getting sucked over onto this
side substance the ethical substance
fate you know uh chicks all right zeus
that we talked about in the last couple
paragraphs
uh substantial being abstract necessity
the spiritual unity into which
everything returns that's that's
self-consciousness
but yet it isn't it it hasn't actually
been uh
brought through to its end because the
next thing that he says is actual
vehicle right the the real
self-consciousness of people involved
is still distinguished from the
substance and from fate
and so then he says it's partly one
thing partly
another so
and here it can be a little bit
confusing i think that the way that we
have to
put this together is breaking this up
into
the chorus and spectators and then the
hero and then we've got this bridging
thing about
realizing hypocrisy realizing
that the true union is not yet present
so what do we have on the side of the
chorus notice that he says it's partly
the chorus
or rather
the crowd of spectators and we've note
we've noted this connection between
chorus and spectators which hegel has
highlighted several paragraphs back
before the chorus is in a certain sense
people within the drama that help to
frame things
but they're also giving the spectators
an entrance into the drama the
spectators are
maybe identifying to some degree with
the chorus giving the course gives them
some cues about what they're supposed to
be feeling hegel here reverts to the
aristotelian
quip about tragedy i don't even want to
call it a theory of tragedy at this
point that has to do with catharsis of
two main emotions fear fruct right
and sympathy is how miller is
translating at mit leiden which
earlier translation pity right fear and
pity that uh aristotle says that tragedy
is supposed to cleanse us of or purify
us of um
so the chorus the crowd of spectators
the movement of divine life fills with
fear as being something alien or in whom
this movement is something close to them
produces merely the emotion of passive
sympathy
um these these emotions are being felt
now notice that hegel is not making
these absolutely central to the essence
of tragedy right he's saying well that's
that's what's going on with those people
who are watching
then we also have the hero he says the
hero this is how the paragraph ends who
appears before the onlooker splits up
into his mask and the actor
into the person in the play
and the actual self the person in the
play is the character right the thing
that's represented over on the other
side the actor is the genuine
self
before that though he says
partly to so far as consciousness is
involved and belongs to the characters
so the characters have
consciousness now right the union is an
external one is a hypocrisy now why
hypocrisy
has a double sense here in in the sense
of noting a contradiction within itself
a vitus book right he doesn't use the
term vitus book there but
speaking against right where you say one
thing but the next thing that you say
contradicts that or the context in which
you say something contradicts what your
your speech act is right so that's one
sense of hypocrisy an older sense of
hypocrisy is one who actually puts on
the mask one who does a performance so
it's it's very much tied in with this
i'd say that that ambiguity
there and he says that why is this a
hypocrisy now we have a third reason
why because the true union that of the
self fate and substance
is not yet present the self is on the
side of actual self-consciousness
substance and fate are along for the
ride but not yet integrated with it
and so
you know at this point there's there's
kind of a
disunity of things that are supposed to
be all coming together
in a unity and this opens up a door
for the mask to come off
the self-consciousness of the hero must
step forth from his mask and present
itself as knowing itself to be the fate
both of the gods of the chorus
and of the absolute powers themselves
and as being no longer separated from
the chorus from the universal
consciousness
paragraph 743 is a very short one and
there's actually not an awful lot going
on here so it shouldn't take too much to
unpack it seems pretty straightforward
the
self-consciousness of the hero
what are we talking about there in the
previous paragraph we had the hero
essentially splitting into the mask
and the actor who is portraying the hero
the actor is now going to assume
more importance qua after qua human
being and the mask is foreshowing it is
representation we have an interesting
use of vocabulary here
in relation to that so the
self-consciousness of the hero does two
things here he says it steps forth from
his mask right so it's it's taking the
mask down
or
doing something that reveals that
there's more than just the mask more
than just the
representation there and that is here
for tretin right it steps out now
hegel might be referencing a part of old
comedy in which the actors actually did
take off their masks apparently and
hurraying audience members by name
calling them out on stuff but we can
also read this in so many other ways
when we talk today about breaking the
fourth wall
it's interesting because it could be the
actor breaking the fourth wall or it
could be the character breaking the
fourth wall and that's part of who the
character is
i mean by definition the actor has to
break the fourth wall but as character
as
masked right
so it does that
and then it presents itself now
presenting itself is a translation of
darstellen right so we have this stellan
term that is there also in forest along
you know the representation picture
thinking
and in both cases there's a stelling a
stallong a placing and you know dark
there um for
in front you know so there's there's
some connections there and also a
difference right so it presents itself
we might ask presents itself to who well
we'll get to that in a moment presents
itself as what
knowing itself and that's the verb there
is is you know veisen vice
it knows itself in the sense of having
cognitive propositional knowledge you
could say to be what the fate the chick
saw
of two things
of the gods of the chorus now why the
gods of the chorus
why
single out that as the understanding of
god's well because the chorus is this
intermediary between us the audience the
spectators and the actual drama that's
taking place so the gods that the chorus
recognizes
and the absolute powers
themselves
and then he says something else that
brings in the chorus that's kind of
interesting
the hero
or the actor the self-consciousness of
the hero is no longer separated from the
chorus no longer getting
no longer divided off from the chorus so
does that mean that the character the
hero is now just one more
schmuck in the crowd of you know the
guards or the old men of the town or
whoever it's supposed to be
well you know
it's not quite clear uh the chorus here
is figured as the universal
consciousness now that's you know
in the past the chorus has been getting
things wrong but now the chorus is the
universal
consciousness it's it's attained a
higher status
than it had um so maybe joining it isn't
quite so bad for the the hero right
and he says uh that's where it ends now
we should think about well who is he
representing or presenting uh
himself
to
to himself to the chorus itself to us
the spectators what's what's going on
here this is not something that is
really happening in the play itself this
is happening within the movement in
hegel's view i would say
of greek drama
and here he's he's doing something
that's rather
a historical and more conceptual he's
saying that comedy is emerging out of
some of the
unresolved issues of tragedy tragedy
understood not just as an art form
but as a way of making sense of god's
self-consciousness the universe fate all
these really important moral and
metaphysical
terms or concepts or realities
comedy has therefore above all the
aspect that actual self-consciousness
exhibits itself as the fate of the gods
these elementary beings are as universal
moments not a self and are not equal
they are it is true endowed with the
form of individuality but this is only
in imagination and does not really and
truly belong to them
the actual self does not have such an
abstract moment for its substance and
content it the subject is raised above
such a moment such a single property and
clothed in this mask it proclaims the
irony of such a property wanting to be
something on its own account
the pretensions of universal
essentiality are uncovered in the self
it shows itself to be entangled in an
actual existence and drops the mask just
because it wants to be something genuine
the self appearing here in its
significance as something actual plays
with the mask which it once put on in
order to act its part
but it as quickly breaks out again from
this illusory character and stands forth
in its own nakedness and ordinariness
which it shows to be not distinct from
the genuine self the actor or from the
spectator
in paragraph 744 hegel is now going to
thematically turn to talking about
comedy now if you're looking for a
general theory of comedy in this and the
next
three paragraphs to follow you're going
to be
rather disappointed because he's not
actually providing that not even just of
greek
you know comedy and not just even of old
comedy as opposed to new comedy but he
is telling us something that's that's
quite important and in the paragraphs to
come we're gonna see some connections
between
comedy
and some of the earlier shapes of
consciousness that we've encountered for
example in the
self-consciousness section i think
there's a connection there with
skepticism
right before the unhappy consciousness
in the reason section and in the
spirit section we'll talk about that
when we get to those those paragraphs so
he's actually referencing comedy comedy
in
the the german right so very clear what
he's talking about and he says it has
the aspect that actual
self-consciousness veer cliche
the one that we've seen talked about in
the two previous paragraphs associated
with the
actor as opposed to the character
exhibits itself
as the fate of the gods now in the
previous two paragraphs
the
self-consciousness the actual
self-consciousness was not yet
integrated with fate
zhixol right
let alone the fate of the gods
now it is going to be connected with
that and in a way that is going to turn
the gods
into something
less god-like something that's
prefiguring
what is happening in the next
section
so he says these elementary beings
elementary veisin right essences
are
as universal moments
not a self
not a self this is gonna be very
important the gods are
stand-ins
figureheads in a way within culture now
this is when we get to a certain point
of cultural development right is not the
earlier viewpoint much more pious much
more
reverent towards the gods the gods are
coming down now as something where we
can say well
what is zeus get actually going to do
apollo interesting concept i don't know
that there's a person who's apollo no
self and then there's something that has
to be like a misprint here
in
uh miller's translation because he says
they're not equal
the german actually says vir click not
not um
actual right
and he says that they're endowed with
the form of individualities right so
they're characters in the drama right
just as they were in the epics
beforehand
but only in imagination nur
only
depicted inwardly that's what ein build
it could be translated as here and i
think we should think about imagination
not just as the individual
imagination that of the spectator that
of the playwright
but we could talk about cultural
imagination so hera so
uh artemis so hermes all these gods that
we associate with things even like the
crazy things that we're not quite sure
where to fit them in like the various
titans
you know or demigods they're just
they're just
build it they're just you know painted
or sketched
within
language within culture within our own
minds and on the stage and in the stage
directions that comprise a
script
so he says
individuality does not really
and truly belong to them
individuality in the sense of agency
individuality in the sense of
responsiveness individuality and all
these these uh things that we we connect
with it
then he goes on and he says the actual
self
does not have such an abstract moment
for its substance and content it's not a
god it is
somebody else the actual self via click
right actual is doing a lot of work on
this this paragraph isn't it
the actual self
is a
subject it doesn't have such a abstract
moment for its substance
and its content its substance and its
inhalt what it is that it is it the
subject is raised above such a moment
such a single property and clothed in it
this mask
it proclaims and here hegel uses the
word irony urani right the irony is such
a property wanting to be something on
its own account let's pause there for a
moment because this goes all the way
back
to the thing in its properties doesn't
it
think about salt one of the examples
that hegel
used in that section in the
consciousness portion of the work
salt
is white
cubicle
has a certain taste to it now that's the
part of it that we would probably be
most tempted to say ah there's the
essence the salty taste
but that is just
a property it is not the
subject of which it is predicated it's
not the subject in which it
inheres and now hegel says
that this subject at this point
is through the mask
right that's going to change very
quickly in this paragraph a subject is
something that is more than just any one
of its properties
right so he says there's an irony of a
property wanting to be something on its
own account what does he mean by irony
usually we take that to mean something
like socratic irony
or
incongruity and it actually works for
both of these
in a way
a property wanting to claim itself to be
more than what it is
is
either ironic or misfounded right
so going on here he says
here we go the pretensions of universal
essentiality
that's over here right vase and height
um
are uncovered in the self
the self
shows itself to be entangled
in actual existence if it is an actual
self
it exists in actual existence it exists
not just within the ideality
the imaginative space of the play
but as the
support
again another term of subject right
for the
drama itself
all of these
actors are real people
who are on a real stage that has been
decorated with whatever you know real
spectacle we don't know what opsis
really means in ancient tragedy but it's
definitely an important thing because
aristotle tells us that in in uh poetics
book one
uh if we only had poetics book two to
help inform this this concept of comedy
in any case
going on
there's a real support to this entangled
in actual existence
the actors are going to take a break and
go off and have something to eat to you
know deal with their famished stomachs
that they haven't been paying attention
to while they've been hiding behind
their mask and putting themselves into
their performance some of them are going
to go off to the bathroom you know and
do their do their things there some of
them are going to like if they don't
have mass retouch their makeup or
they're gonna have to readjust their
mask or their costume the director might
come out and say okay good job everybody
now let's have a great second act
these are all
actual existence
that we're entangled in
so
he goes in and he says
it drops the mask
now here we have a really interesting
motivation coming up why does it drop
the mask
because it wants to be as miller
translates it something genuine now the
german here is at vas rectus
not just genuine not not just actus
right so it wants to be something that
really is
doing justice
uh
to
whatever is going on
it wants to be right
right in the very primordial sense of
the term not just conforming to certain
rules or something like that
right in the sense of
displaying something that truly is the
way it is
think about all the actors
over millennia
playing if not just behind masks but
behind makeup behind characters
and you know so many of them having to
be a certain part oftentimes not
speaking only saying the lines that
they're allowed to maybe getting to
ad-lib once in a while
if they're you know allowed to if
they're in the elite
and
they are stuck behind this mask they
feel themselves to be
good at faking
well at some point they actually want to
like let the mask down and say here's
what i'm really like here's what i have
to say
so he says
it's entangled in actual existence drops
the mask because it wants to be
something genuine
the self appearing here in its
significance as something actual
plays with the mask
would it which it once put on in order
to act its part
but it as quickly breaks out again from
this what's the mask an illusory
character
and stands forth
in its own nakedness
and ordinariness
which it shows to be not distinct from
the genuine self the actor
or
from the spectator
now this last passage that concludes
this paragraph is bringing up something
about comedy
that we did get from aristotle and that
hegel is incorporating here without
referencing him the person in tragedy
you know the character is supposed to be
this very important person who has a you
know
tragic flaw or screw-up however you want
to translate hamartia sin right
the person in comedy is more like the
rest of us schmucks the rest of us
schlubs the rest of us slobs out there
in the audience who are not you know
perfect people
we're not you know totally imperfect
either we are kind of a mix and a mess
and if we're developing we're on the way
the actor reveals themselves to be like
that
different than the character than
they're
playing
standing forth in their own nakedness
and ordinariness
right
not distinct from the genuine self the
actor or from us
the spectator
comedy is
comedy in part because we can
see ourselves in there a little bit more
ourselves
not just some ideal self but ourselves
in it
so we've got a very interesting contrast
going on here between the actual self
and subject and between the self and the
mask within it
as compared to the gods who are now
in a
not necessarily one down position
but certainly without any real agency or
selfhood of their own
you